there's a reason that uber chose
Pittsburgh in its two words for nagumo
one of their clear clear demonstrations
of the fact that academic research over
a period of time has the power to change
the world what is fourth and we had some
manual drive but very good bit of
automatic right kinda hard to tell the
difference so when you're in one load or
the other I was particularly pleased to
see the Carnegie Mellon graduates in the
front row seats and each right you're
going to have more and more data comes
in which is going to make the right
better and better with drawing this is
Big Data machine learning artificial
intelligence when all our sweet spot for
Carnegie Mellon and this is why I think
innovation is so closely connected to
research universities it's like Carnegie
Mellon and you miss your fix for working
together have the power to change the
world and this is a very good example
this
you